today is the first ever lou gehrig day
june 2nd was chosen because on this date
in 1925 lou gehrig made the first of
many starts at first base for the new
york yankees it is also the date where
he tragically passed away from the
disease that would later bear his name
at the age of thirty-seven the good
night army for the race i've already
seen three times this year and we've
seen him good bad and somewhere in the
middle and all three times he normally
though is good and he has been pitching
well oh two down and here is austin
meadows 3-2
struck him out swinging though in the
inning no runs
no hits no one left at the end of a half
10 to nothing yankees are coming about
today it will be shane mcclanahan who is
renewing a
appearances against the yankees who made
his major league debut against them in
the postseason last year and two way
here is gio arcella
a runner at first with two men out
and the pit swung on and drilled a deep
right it is high it is far good it's
gone
geo archela goes the opposite way and
drills a two-run home run in the
right-field seats
geo oshella the most happy fella
no he's the most happy bella a two-run
blast torres at 259 two homers and 19
rbis
rugnet o'dore waiting on deck
now mcclanahan again from the wide and
another full count pitch fastball strike
three quality got him looking for the
slider and vapor locked them with a
fastball at 96 and that'll do it for new
york there's a go ahead run joey wendell
and the pitch struck him out swinging a
sweeping breaking ball
that's the second strikeout for monty
well here's taylor walls
wall swings and lines one great pick by
arshella throws the first in time to end
the inning a shella
he stole a run from tampa bay that was a
bullet headed to left field and he got
it on one hop assistant he is probably
the most underrated player in baseball
indeed not on not around here he's not
almost for sure no runs two hits too
late dude
hit 194 this year with five home runs
and a cut and a miss
strikeout to begin the bottom of the
second second strikeout for mcclanahan
miguel andujar hitting at 239 with a
couple homers four knocked in
and cut the miss
you turn the light up over now to detail
the mayhew with two on and two out
runners go the 3-2
swing and a high fly ball to center
field but phillips goes back has plenty
of room and makes the catch
and that will retire the side so the
mayhew leaves and comes forward
now montgomery is ready to go and he's
ahead of a rose arena oh and two
struck him out swinging change he's way
ahead
so there are two way strikeout number
three for montgomery aaron judge reached
out to fielder's choice and
scored his first time two balls two
strikes to judge mcclanahan from the
line and throws got him swinging to
change up away two out nobody on leaves
it for geo urchella
now i'll cut the miss
and down goes gio urchala and on this
lou gehrig day in new york shane
mcclanahan gets the middle part of the
yankee order one two three here's manuel
go with the tying run at second
second third nobody out down two nothing
in the fourth and here is margot
grounded a second is only time
one and two to count after meeting on
the mound the pitch to margot swinging a
hard ground ball to short meadows breaks
for home but they throw to third and tag
out brussel
reaching on the play margot run batted
in and it's 2-1 here is clint frazier
with the bases loaded now one out now
here's the 1-0 to frazier
swung on grounded up the middle base hit
center field torres scores here comes
odor and he scores it is a two-run base
hit for clint frazier and the yankees
take a 4-1 lead
and here's judge
he was grounded to third reaching on a
fielder's choice and struck out thompson
ready to go
the runners are off on the payoff pitch
swinging a ground ball towards third
picked up by wendell here's his throw
into first in time and the side is
retired so
the rays stay on the fringes
and even though they trail by a larger
margin when the inning began
they are still in this game
gandhi is over two
4-1 new york here on the top of the
fifth two on one out in field for the
yankees still looking to turn two and
now we'll get him out of the inning
montgomery ready he does not go in the
pitch he's swung out and lifted in the
air to left field but not deep
back a step or two and now making the
catches on duhar tagging it third as
walls he's going to come in and score
so it's a sacrifice fly rbi to left
field by yandi diaz and the race cut the
lead to four to two
judges bounced into a fielder's choice
score to run 1-2
swung on and lifted
in the air left center field but
playable phillips drifting over to his
right is there to make the catch in that
will
retire the side so the yankees get a
couple men aboard and the big boys can't
get him in so chew on no one out and
here is the left-handed of brett
phillips they'll see if they have him
bunt to move the runners over with the
top of the order coming up
the 99th pitch coming from montgomery
will be a season high for him
fight his way through the seventh inning
runners go
and the strikeout of philip saw a double
steal
as now the tying runs at second base and
that's going to be it for montgomery
so philip strikes out and wendell steals
third wall still second second and third
two out the pincher choi batting for
yandy diaz left hand hitter
one ball one strike to jimen choy
he's need a big hit
and here comes swinging a ground ball
off a little wise ago karim stored
second backhanding in center field is
odor and has no play
in to score is wendell to third base
walls and it's 4-3 new york and now
here's another really good left-hand
hitter in austin meadows
once again the 3-2
hit on the ground to short gleber torres
throws to first
and the yankees get out of the seventh
with the lead
[Applause]
by the hair on their chinny chin chin
so walls at second
kier meyer is at first and back to the
top of the order and randy arose arena
who does not have a good line tonight he
walked in the first and then struck out
the next three times
2-2 swing and a miss
got him on the slider big out
g-man choi pinch it in this game had an
infield single 3-2
swing of the miss
meadows has 39 runs batted in and 13
home runs
first and second two outs yankees up by
one four to three
oh two coming to meadows with two else
the pitch is hit on the ground to
chapman chapman throws to first in time
ball game over yankees win the
yankees when